he was original Polynesian sponsor this
seals electrical skill even a song
consiguió trap I didn't mean a sizable
sugar deposited what about you are you
neski topic you brainy my budget is a
drill poke you Ricardo neski impression
ology who kicked a CodeRed father he
votes Ozzy Soraka de conseguir la
maestra Cabrini you pixel men organized
go cellular change let's keep orgy
ecology alfalfa Z character no species
of a provocative Itza guys last year we
gave you the top 10 clutches in Rainbow
six siege now you seem to like that one
and kept asking us for more so we
thought what the hell why not do an
entire best of dedicated just to our six
clutches in pro play now for this video
we are gonna be looking at the best
clutch or kick moments from our six the
best timer scam clutches and of course
the best ace clutches let's get on with
them well there you go another logic
bomb is the smoke will choke out shuttle
he'll toss it a smoke grenade of his own
and push it with the alcohol 12 all a
great shot all the way across to marry
you a long angle with a recoil that can
be quite unwieldly to control yeah see
you race hill inside a connector he's
got great position but he loses his
shuttle and another one nearly fell he
misses the judge but the flick behind
there's only what is going on an
incredible clutch now it's a 3v3
shockwave holding down on to do it will
push out slides and fix up know that
there goes alpha man is all to VIII's
all nuts nixon you know the defuser will
go down in the back of arsenal but
shockwave with a great killin - Hicks
will try and get another one get easily
trade it out by you know it's all down
to him - won't be tube post blunt he has
the punt down and he has the kills he
gets another shepherd but no with a 3k
to finish it up oh my god so that bore
on to Lee just turned into a two-on-two
with 25 seconds to go Penghu still here
another shield on the gun Stukas gonna
rush on out of their lackeys gonna pick
up one they know the last ones in
connector
like Gangu will get the shot there on a
snuke and last man lackey gonna be
yellow stairs he's got the camera above
him he knows he's picked it in love with
ten seconds to go he's telling Lackey to
go Bush he knows it now Lackey right now
is gonna be actually underneath will
drop through he doesn't realize the
hatch got opened up pingu's now pushing
him he just I was gonna rush it but he's
gonna get the cut half of the round yet
to go and crazy papaya and we'll get
spark JC also gets Rafael and papaya on
a [ __ ] one under bebo parade is the
final defender for vitality we're
shaping up for map number three unless
brick can clutch it out he's got a whole
minute to work with here Norah on the
other hand are going to have to start
droning out and looking for their
opponents they don't want to jump the
gun they don't want to lose because they
stack up and get caught in the same
spray or anything silly like that so
they're gonna calculate this move and
push in likely all together EMP is
coming out to clear any potential traps
a nice single being played from red he's
gonna miss the shots though goes for
another one onto the windows for balcony
gets the second follow-up shot on - JJ
getting the stature but the diffusers
being planted right now in your eyelids
and all what is happening by Tony take
it oh she just made a sound by walking
through the metal detector oh geezr
takes down drugs very nice little every
six down revolts however three people
situation all down to GC ah
now it's UV white piece around oh my god
easy coach this house so easily is all
down slash in a 1v1 situation all down
to GC r triangle is just I would get
that fuse it down what a nice few shots
there as just padding your stats takes
down out easy and try to find out where
exactly am i lash is it's gonna be
trying to pay him out B gonna know that
slash is only one of these vertical
angles he knows it against the book here
he knows that spoke didn't you gonna try
and fake it oh what a shot takes down /
30 seconds on the clock
Brian is gonna start pushing and he did
pick up that diffuser and gets the kill
on two lucky as shorts do come weeks
from now LMGs there's those shot
throwing easily Brian gets himself
another kill has a lane
well falsies the smoke and those
chuckling stays to a 1vs1 Brian vs. meet
B hose then stopping a 4v2 has end up
into a 1vs1 but from below me P still
has Lee c4 and brand has actually
thought the putt he could have got that
plant toy so this is where the Intel's
gonna be fed and he is gonna get tight
and meet me essentially should be able
to win this Rhine fight he's actually
gonna dig it up first then potentially
transfer to c4 and so we'll get Toledo
see my [ __ ] does make me gets the
coach X has chosen to rotate down the
white stairs this could be the moment of
truth here for nomads if he gets the
right flank he will get one but not the
second and he has not down to the
defuser which means it will likely be
planted in a moments here inside of
dorms spray through the wall 4x just
narrowly missing some shots there on two
yellow both of these attackers aren't
low HP and one will be down the second
one marked and this could still be a
clutch 4x it doesn't have to fight
against a mirror window luckily for him
which means this retake is definitely
possible he sees the spray and the
tracers give away the position but the
vault from capital might be the perfect
play hex is on the defuser but he knows
he can't stick it because of the repel
but the vault
oh Willy halftime is the real question
we're nearing Ellen's the last legs of
what is very possible but it's just
gonna be the nice one second difference
only time will tell
we can't possibly know Wow X what a
clutch canto gets Britt but read
response on the canto and I'll get still
a defender in the site and that's gonna
be you know who gets B boo and as spark
gets pushed on he is very wisely not
getting initials right get that red ball
Kel Wilkie now in a 1vs1
he might have the yokai still but it's a
post plant situation and half a diffuser
has been whittled down spark is in a
perfect spot to clutch this right now
now he's very likely gonna be hit by the
yokai which will Kesey's be using right
now and he has
indeed been hit by that very drone but
he's choosing to move over to blue
stairs playing the long game expecting
to push from Wilkie in here it comes
Wilkie checks the wrong angle and he
goes back in for the defuser there's no
time
smart clutches it out in a one versus
four swing my steeple at this old
beautiful success so lucky penguin F
missing pegye by - horses push the team
a new project with this university is it
so - oh my god
by the time you do - laughs - God
Almighty Allah with supriya's a mind too
much he'll sell akira-kun saggy hikky
Hagin on from HD interrogatories a free
to the ad right especially related to
the Cobra Sarah Kelly Jose Castro
mementos ABC pretend oh oh
Sarah Kira back on CB sniffing the air
back here Brando movem ehe
gonna find asteroids playing a bond
never cut down one of the roamers on
phases behalf Koga and Yodas vanquished
leaving Kanto riccati to deal with the
three remaining members of phase and
very quickly he will reduce it to two
with Maringa and yuna just waiting put
the shotgun of Maringa looking at the
corner of the doorway Kanto doesn't
think he can vault he sees the mirror
for a second his position in bathroom
giveth away but he's gonna give himself
easy access in towards service and this
is a very winnable position with that
r4c in the hands of the Finn I need to
grab the defuser it's quite a ways away
and moringa crowed with the shotgun
blast Kanto around the corner silencing
the crowd slip it inside a small tower
looking for the flank he sees the IQ and
the UMP will do good work he's looking
for a fourth pub and will get it it's
only up to plus to keep this together in
blast takes up to me he looks for
smothering he cuts him down it's a
triple supplies he looks for another
shot a will peak on out
it's a 1v1 and this is an extremely
winnable position just by the green bins
last will peak on up the all to come in
he sees the maestro and blast a huge
collection what a play from blast is
good early on
Oh Ruffin missing miss Johnson canto
will punish him for it the meantime
Pangu has come in and how does he win it
enemy will go down hungry though for the
finisher of can't Iraq any hungry with a
shotgun shell still one more against the
two alive here he'll find one in tropi
diffusers fill the hands of Koga but not
for long hungry with a fool key to put
it all up Penta sports much spark and
Yuna are low on HP I'm gonna throw in a
Candela here as hing moves on him spawns
gets one is one spawns gets two they're
all falling down you and I with one more
leaving one out live bibo fighting for
his life on the ash here pulls out the
Pikes engine takes it before you gave me
four kills in a row none of the members
are secret or even remotely close to the
site they appear to be towards the other
side of the map which means that fabien
setting down that one EEP DD as you
mentioned the entry denial device it's
gonna mean that it could possibly catch
somebody from secret there and it's if
you've already drone that out you're not
necessarily anticipating a 50 or 40 or
60 damage trap being there Oh easy gets
taken down and Bobby and makes the
correct call he's gonna try to jump on
the free kill but don't be don't do as
they've lost control of site another
down this time on to Allen's fabien will
clean up all he goes in with the 3-piece
set up c4 is gonna get thrown by BC
won't hit anybody but they do spot both
players moving in problem is both
players coming to the same position all
they can do is just show them out BC
gets one can't get the second that'll be
a quick drop from Vale spots the second
takes him out as well and then the third
valkyrie all on canadian can he clutch
this the in-game leader the infamous
player from the most famous players in
the entire game you see the bomb might
get set up c4 is gonna get thrown but
he's not ready for comes in for the
night oh my god Phil gets the kill
canadian gets dropped and what up can
not believe this kill you guys teammate
eclipse watching if there's a push
through security skies will take out /
no it will give this eclipse with one
two more eclipses all this is winnable
they will need to defuse and the time
running out but he clipped but robe will
take it but raid to finish things off
how does this happen
13 seconds left the attackers are
pressure for time rifts gets cameraman
Astro responds on to Corey and it's just
back and forth you're go Hondo with the
knife on K as aces from the hallway will
get Astro going on a second one for
himself but aces juts them down zero on
the clock but the defuser has been
planted the pistol from ace what is
happening he takes down Billy managed to
recover the defuser a little bit and
just go for the blood and you said he
was over but cybers managed to recover
this reach T thumb PSK he's all Doutzen
s keepo chase around
oh wait used to Gail of the newbies he's
the deagle he does it he gets to you
head shows in a row will take up Yoko
from inside of bucha but he oh wow a
second one for sexy kick he should have
gone down and you cool actually down him
one the last defender here he has to it
down attackers as well three people
crawling on the floor a 1vs1 and oh no
sexy cake though has picked himself back
up because he's playing Sophia and he's
gonna be able to push one with the brie
fires they would makes it what just
happened
now there are no shortage of hype
clutches in Rainbow six siege but a
clutch where the time runs out well
that's something special because in a
game like siege you're not just fighting
against the enemy team you're fighting
against the clock as well and you cannot
afford to forget about that hidden enemy
they're gonna need to go for a plant
Mark's coming out he just needs to salt
hide but the time is in there slash you
do I to live cloud 9 what are you doing
need to be over side off to oversight
for mantis for 20 20 seconds to go how
old is gonna force in themselves in last
minute this could even just be a single
play from sweet black to deny the plants
especially that smoke right in the
doorway there was a
it is the lost baby band sweet flex kind
of pace brought out of thought though
this plot thing oh my gosh your gun this
is surely going to work infected death
and then is gonna be the clutch bus
sweet black race all comes up on a flank
he'll take one down will not get farther
oh no map a team kill after cameraman
gets one and it'll be a 3v2 ten seconds
left to marry you and walk up and
engaging with the Montaigne map will be
there picking up yet another rag Walker
will need to come back to site all you
need to do is stop that defuse he'll be
greeted by a Montaigne trying to rush
past diffuser Nina cannot cover what did
it say play from lockup Aces waiting for
his opportunity that youkai is doing so
much work excellent job to Leon and
making it happen it's not even gonna be
fun oh wow what a play from him you
could see that liven is doing his best
to try and dispatch it but it's just not
gonna happen
as the time didn't windows down to the
last 10 seconds Hicks is gonna force his
way into the site and take out a Lambs
like he's still in a perfect denial
position he'll whip out the shotgun to
make it happen and it looks like he's
gonna not make be successful
aces will finish him off the yokai drone
though from Leon will deny the plant in
the final seconds visit each request on
the pool bar but the look on so you stop
reaching Danny my Summa capacitor
Dornish what's he gonna shop with this
year though but abisco significant
minister idea - ah god that does again
Gd and refracts onto Ness can hug for
privacy for now no oh but it misses no
the smoke ugh sword a big mistake and
liquid will capitalize and go on shut
down it's all up to panic oh but he'll
stop the defuser all tracks it's all up
to liquid to get it back and go for the
plan but then run out of time and black
dragons a beautiful recovery canadian
has a tiny portion healthy old that
Pangu down Bobby and all alone in
theater he sticks the diffusor waits for
the audio kim ki-young will need to
cover there is a c4 from Fabian he
Prime's the Canadian falls off he goes
down none we'll need to get him he has
only ten seconds and he enters they will
be in a standoff can he get the Valkyrie
two seconds young pushes up running at a
time keep your eye on B see the mirror
is still playing he does see the valve
in I don't know if Canadian is
determined that he's been drone out I'll
go for a couple pre fires can he manage
to hit it oh no
Canadian why are you there Fabien with a
very easy kill and it's gonna be up to
BC to clutch yet again the mirror
playing inside a small office he'll go
for a c4 tosses it out
BC this has to live for two seconds can
paint you find him so Evil Geniuses will
stick the third round BC another clutch
well guys so far we've talked about
clutches with a handful of kills and
clutches with no kills but here is the
cream of the crop the best ace clutches
in pro rainbow six why she's not toss
him to c4 at this stage gonna put shots
in a Miss bolt which is gonna pick up
the kill on - I'd like as he beats all
this default sauce gonna come out from
Julie oh you're not gonna hit its mark
absorb that linking into the site psycho
does eventually pick up a steam for kill
but not before panco takes out Julia and
psycho getting another one on - panic oh
so two versus one it's all down to cycle
to deny this plant or get two kills and
get the defuse off the planet is gonna
go down I'm not sure if the attackers
are aware of where cycle is playing
currently but book is Rob's a very tight
angle but because advanced air cycle is
able to talk about killings hog Vlad
narrowly missing out on the kill on to
ions Alice gets a cycle gets the kill on
two ions and that is it
the diffusers going to go down what a
clutch from the valkyrie I think psycho
is potentially a very good player hungry
will not get leadoff kill this time but
Britt will get paid for by ripped as he
takes two down with them several
imitating para and it's 3v3 that
diffuser in the hands of Vale getting
planted and they will stick the landing
rips a third kill knock KS eliminated
from bee boo the glass looking for a
fourth tries to behead bee boo inside a
dirt tunnel man can't
it goes for another shot before helium
but they're gonna have to try to figure
out where Vail is the Havanna is tucked
in safely behind the cabinet they see
her downer and now it's only up to the
class they need to drop at the same time
and hopefully they'll be able to hold
off that DMR but they are running out of
time spark starts to diffuse be be
looking for the glass tries to take out
the yellow rip so forth
is he gonna get it tries to shoot away
unable to get rips the ace and what up
takes this Jango beeboo and sparks and
that's how you play glass c4 will come
out to counter but the EMP counters the
c4 in turn mint up close and personal
with these enemies managing to flash
them but stuck in the crossfire it's
really hard to get this engagement in
his favour he will finally take out
Saleh when it's his team falling one
after another putting more pressure on
mint able to get to his last teammate
mofo Joe at the bottom a stairs at 3-4
min incredible pistol play and he has
the diffuser going for the plant behind
black box this is the perfect position
for an to plant solo Hojo's doing his
best to cover but he's gonna lose the
fight to Redeemer forcing mint into an
ace situation he's gonna get the Forte
he has the mirror window and the flash
Hey
they ferment and around all on blitz
beautiful this is the whole d'Alene's of
the site poder laying down down and
Nick's on the flank finally finds a
Filipino he goes down Kenny deny the
plunge
those ad s's will be in vain inside of
the garage aces flash he's got the LMG
plate up and he'll just see all the
utility pieces he will be dumped in
vases gets one psycho is aware that
there's one playing on stairs and Leah
will take out an eel fighter plant going
down somewhat successfully but no aces
seasoned ages coming in can he get it to
big kills from aces he sees another a
third aces oh my goodness in a one thing
done you know he's still got the
diffuser to work through giulio will now
watch and who's gonna prevail on this
bite a sledge versus the maestro but
look at this one frag grenade remaining
from Julie oh and he's priming it on the
defuser he'll toss it out in Aces will
he live we'll get off the plan the
maestro will shoot away at the wall oh
my god how does this happen
oh my word ace is a huge clutch and
he'll get the defuser fanatic mind god
what around one around well guys that's
all for this week now if you do want
more content just like this and
specifically more Rainbow six well you
already you know what to do reach the
like button nitro cell that subscribe
button and lean spam that comment
section I'll see you next time thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button
[Music]